bonsoir
pour commencer en fait je voudrais vous
poser une question est ce que vous
faites partie des 60 % de gens que la
culture rend plus heureux c'est le
credoc l'institut d'études spécialisé
dans la consommation et les modes de vie
qui a très sérieusement et
rigoureusement observé que les individus
qui dans l'année écoulée ont fait une
visite culturelle un musée une expo ou
un lieu culturel ont 60% de plus de
chances de se déclarer eux-mêmes plus
heureux ça en dit long sur la place de
la culture dans nos vies et puis on a de
la chance parce qu'en france on a plein
d'occasions de se rendre plus heureux
une année comme 2014 c'est plus de 200
millions d'entrées au cinéma c'est plus
de 280 millions de volumes de livre
vendu 60 millions de visites rien que
dans les musées de france
et pourtant pourtant quand on arrive au
seuil de la sphère professionnelle en
tout cas de la sphère de l'entreprise
il est convenu de faire abstraction de
toute cette dimension de notre humanité
pourquoi parce que c'est sérieux comme
maintenant il faut faut être efficace
faut être productif et pourtant
l'entreprise a énormément à gagner dans
les connexions avec le monde des arts et
de la culture
alors vous me direz mais mais ça existe
ça se fait ya justement le mécénat puis
le secteur du luxe on a parlé alors
effectivement quand on évoque ensemble
et deux mots culture et entreprises il
ya des choses qui nous viennent mais
c'est une vision qui reste quand même
assez souvent parcellaire et ce que je
voudrais vous inviter à faire ce soir
c'est justement de revisiter cette
vision sous la forme d'un passage en
revue et d'une remise en cause d'un
certain nombre d'idées reçues sur le
sujet de cinq grandes idées reçues et la
première justement c'est cette idée que
abba finalement ce ne serait que le
mécénat
alors le mécénat culturel des
entreprises en france
clairement c'est quelque chose de
formidable il ya quarante mille
entreprises en france qui s'investissent
dans le mécénat culturel
ça veut dire qu'elle arrive à injecter
de manière cumulée 1 selon les
statistiques de
l'amicale plus de 360 millions d'euros
pour des projets culturels qui autrement
verrait pas le jour où ou n'aboutirait
pas mais pour autant faut rappeler
quelque chose c'est par définition le
mécénat c'est un soutien sans
contrepartie directe à des causes
d'intérêt général et donc ça ça veut
dire que ça le mec complètement dans le
registre du don de la philanthropie et
comme vous le savez il n'ya pas beaucoup
d'entreprises qui ont pour raison
sociale d'être dans le don est dans la
philanthropie
alors forcément de ce fait là le mécénat
reste relativement marginal dans les
relations avec entre l'entreprise et les
arts et la culture est en fête et le
reste parce que on le verra je pense ya
beaucoup d'autres façons d'interagir qui
sont possibles entre les arts la culture
et l'entreprise mais aussi que cette
idée d'être seulement dans le don dans
la philanthropie dans cette logique
d'une aide des entreprises vers la
culture est réductrice et qu'on peut
tout à fait s'inscrire dans une idée est
bien que les arts et la culture peuvent
être des leviers et peuvent apporter des
bénéfices réels aux entreprises dans des
relations n'ont pas
d'instrumentalisation comme on l'entend
parfois mais vraiment dans des synergies
une relation gagnant gagnant
alors ça vous me direz bah oui c'est
justement quelque chose qu'on voit et on
le voit dans un secteur et peut-être
même que d'ailleurs on le voit que dans
ce secteur ça c'est bon que pour le luxe
et la mode
alors évidemment il ya des liens tout à
fait direct comme illustré derrière moi
par cette illustration d'une vitrine
vuitton décoré par takashi murakami ab
nombreux artistes contemporains qui ont
collaboré avec cette grande maison via
des connexions presque naturellement
direct entre l'univers de la création de
la mode et du luxe et l'univers de la
création artistique et culturelle mais
pour autant je voudrais vraiment que
vous est convaincue qu' aucun domaine
d'activité aucune marque n'est a priori
incompatibles avec les arts et la
culture
pourquoi parce que finalement ce que
permet une expérience culturelle et
artistique
c'est de donner une dimension sensible à
une identité d'apporter ce que les grecs
appelaient l'esthétique au cdr cette
sorte de d'expérience esthétique au sens
premier du terme de véhiculer des
émotions des expériences sensibles et
pour une entreprise pour une marque qui
a besoin de véhiculer un projet de sens
le sens qu'elle donne à son activité
c'est extrêmement important de pouvoir
le faire avec une dimension sensible et
émotionnelle qui va permettre de
favoriser l'impact la notoriété la
considération alors j'irai même plus
loin je pense que plus une entreprise
est dans un domaine d'activité qui est
peu perceptible peu visible pas très
pâle pas très vite ou bi par exemple
d'un plus il peut être opportun pour
elle d'avoir recours à une expérience
culturelle ou artistique pour s'exprimer
comme par exemple cette société
d'immobilier commercial qui s'appelle la
sfl la société foncière lyonnaise qui te
pupu re année à développer un programme
s'appelle mémoire contemporaine qui
consiste à donner carte blanche à un
artiste pour intervenir sur un bâtiment
ici vous voyez l'intervention d'un
artiste d'un jeune artiste cher à kamel
mennour françois morlaix sur un de ces
immeubles de la rue de rivoli qui permet
de ben voilà d'apporter une
singularisation de données ce décalage
qu'on évoquait sur la vision aussi des
partenaires et des clients de la société
ce qui est important en fait c'est pas
tant son domaine d'activité
c'est vraiment travailler de se poser la
question ce que j'appellerais son
potentiel culturel de marque c'est à
dire en partant de son identité de ses
valeurs de marque se poser vraiment la
question et réfléchir à quel peut être
le champ d'expression culturelle qui
serait pertinent pour aider à son
développement
jean d'expression culturelle ça peut
être régies de créativité artistique
musicale
deux spectacles vivants mais aussi de
gastronomie de mode ça peut être aussi
un registre d'expression plus
patrimoniale fait plus référence à
l'histoire à la mémoire
et puis il faut réfléchir aussi aux
canaux à utiliser qu'elles seront le
type d'initiatives culturelles que l'on
va prendre
est-ce que ça va être une collaboration
avec un artiste autour d'un produit
autour d'un lieu est-ce que ça va être
la création d'un événement est ce que ça
va être lancé un projet ou un prix de
marques qui a un champ de possibles qui
est presque illimitées et c'est pour ça
que dans ce champ des possibles ce qui
est important c'est de vraiment faire en
sorte de créer cette cette sorte
d'alchimie ce moment où il ya une vraie
résonance entre un univers d'identité de
marque et d'entreprises d'un côté et un
univers de référence culturelle
artistique de l'autre et que ces deux
langages finalement se rencontrent et
s'amplifie l'un l'autre
quand par exemple shediac marketing
compagnies ont fait un projet pour une
société comme disney qui consiste en une
exposition une vente caritative
intitulée le mal pour le bien en
demandant à des créateurs de tous
horizons de finalement recréer un de
leurs souvenirs d'enfance d'un film de
walt disney mobilisant des notions de
bien et de mal on arrive justement avec
des exemples parmi d'autres comme ceux
ci un manteau de cruella qui est revu
par chantal thomass a ce regard
hypnotique vous rappelez de l'affreux
serpent cas dans le livre de la jungle
vu par l'artiste contemporain lionel
estève ou encore un miroir magique de
sorcières par laurent pernot à chaque
fois ici on voit vraiment la rencontre
entre un univers d'inspiration qui est
celui des fils de walt disney est
vraiment un registre artistique le
langage de chacun de ces créateurs qui
leur est propre et qu on reconnaît bien
quand on est familier de leur travail
ça c'est important parce qu'on y si on
réussit vraiment avoir cette synergie
qui permet finalement une prise de
parole de marques différentes
décalé qui va atteindre d'autres publics
aussi en l'occurrence au service de ma
la sortie d'un film la sortie
film magnifique avec angelina jolie à
quelques mois alors ici on va peut-être
s'acheminer vers une autre idée reçue
c'est de se dire bah ouais effectivement
ça a l'air de fonctionner c'est pas mal
pour faire un coup de com en quoi une
opé comme ça un peu isolé qui qui va un
peu raisonnée ça c'est une double idée
reçue double idée reçue parce que
d'abord reste indre le champ à la
communication
c'est réducteur et puis faire
abstraction de la notion de durée qui
est importante cette idée de faire un
coup c'est vraiment une erreur une
illustration pour ça est-ce que vous
reconnaissez ces messieurs pas
d'auvergne out here montois dans la
salle parce qu'il s'agit des frères
andré et edouard michelin les créateurs
il ya plus d'un siècle du groupe de
pneumatiques éponyme et puis aussi sans
a priori de savoir danser à terme là de
vrais grands pronier du brain contente
culturel c'est-à-dire de ce
développement d'un contenu culturel
destiné à servir au développement de la
considération d'une marque et si je
pense évidemment à tous développement
des guides michelin dès 1900 les frères
michelin sorte le premier guide sur la
restauration et l'hôtellerie
ah oui puisque à l'époque le parc
automobile s'est à peine quelques
milliers de voitures
si vous voulez développer le l'univers
du pneumatique qui a intérêt à motiver
un peu cette révolution et puis à
rassurer sur le fait que à l'époque
c'était un peu aventures de partir en
août au et que ban on pouvait se
rassurer pour un voyage sans surprise au
contraire plein de promesses de
découvert de bons moments à passer et
cesseront que le contenu culturel de la
marque michelin a joué pendant des
années avec après ben le la création des
étoiles michelin pour hiérarchiser les
restaurants mais aussi les guides verts
qui sont venus accompagner les guides
rouges qui au document vraiment les
curiosités patrimoniales culturelles
touristiques des différentes régions et
aujourd'hui cette activité de contenu
vraiment culturel de marque chez
michelin est une activité à part entière
et même une entité légale qui fait que
ça qui sort des centaines de titres de
guide des plans des cartes mais aussi
tous les dispositifs numériques qui vont
avec aujourd'hui autour de viamichelin
donc là vous m'accorderez conte avec
cette expérience plus que séculaire
on n'est pas dans l'idée de juste faire
un coup de com
et de fait il ya beaucoup d'autres
entreprises qu'on me l'expérience
culturelle ou artistique au coeur de
leur développement ou de celui de leurs
produits ou leurs marques comme absolut
vodka comme les porcelaine bernardaud
red bull avec sa musique academy
mais ce que je voudrais souligner à ce
stade c'est que on parle beaucoup ici de
rayonnement extérieur grâce à une
intervention artistique ou culturel mais
c'est important aussi de voir la
dimension interne que ça peut avoir
comme dans cet exemple d'une simple pme
françaises -société doublet qui est
spécialisée dans le textile et qui en
fait à travers son programme de mécénat
de compétences a conçu et produit les
pochoirs dont le street artist jef
aérosol a eu besoin pour faire cette
grande fresque géante que vous
connaissez peut-être lé à paris vous
avez tout à côté de l'église
saint-eustache derrière le centre
pompidou eh ben pour cette entreprise
c'est vraiment le moyen de véhiculer le
sens de son activité et contribuer à la
fierté au sentiment d'appartenance en
interne alors à ce stade si j'ai réussi
à être un peu convaincant peut-être
qu'il ya une autre une autre menace une
autre idée reçue qui nous guette c'est
de se dire bah ouais finalement c'est
super l'art et la culture c'est un peu
la martingale c'est l'outil magique on a
un problème d'identité d'image on va y
mettre un coup d'arrêt aux cultures et
puis et puis ça marche à tous les coups
alors attention parce que oui on a vu on
a vu que ça marchait
mais ça marche avec un certain degré
d'exigence et de rigueur comme j'allais
dire tous les autres registres de
l'activité de l'entreprise et on peut
peut-être souligné trois points vraiment
majeurs justement d'exigence dans une
démarche artistique ou culturelle
d'entreprise c'est d'abord la légitimité
la qualité culturelle de ce qu'on va
faire
lac à partir du moment où on est dans
une prise de parole culture elle-même en
tant qu'entreprise on va être jugés sur
des critères artistiques ou culturelles
et donc fois vaut être à la hauteur de
blaye plus haut degré d'excellence dans
ce registre là aussi le deuxième point
d'excellence c'est l'authenticité c'est
d'être vraiment sincère et authentique
dans cette démarche là
par rapport à tout ce qu'ont fait
d'autres tout ce qu'on dit dos tout ce
qu'on exprime d'autres dans son identité
d'entreprise
et puis le troisième point c'est un
certain ancrage dans la durée et dans la
cohérence de ses actions pour que
justement on ressortent vraiment comme
l'entreprise comme un véritable acteur
du champ culturel et d'expression
qu'elle a choisi alors qu'est ce qui se
passe si on fait pas ça ben c'est comme
pour tout il ya des retours de bâton
le retour de bâton alors à l'extrême ça
peut être que j'oserais appelé être
inculte être un cube c'est quoi c'est
manquer totalement de discernement sur
finalement des signes ou des
manifestations culturelles dont on voit
pas du tout l'effet qu'elles peuvent
produire voire même le scandale qu elles
peuvent produire là j'ai un exemple
extrême c'est par exemple le sahara et
l'année dernière nous a sorti ce
magnifique création qui convoque à la
fois l'étoile jaune et pyjamas rayés sur
le même t-shirt grosse rechute parce que
quelques années avant il avait déjà fait
les sacs à main indien 10 ans avec des
vraies petites soit stick à des croix
gammées dedans donc là je vous accorde
qu on est sur un exemple extrême mais un
exemple réel quoi c'est des produits qui
ont été réfléchies qu'on suit à beaucoup
de gens qui ont travaillé dessus ils ont
été sortis très vite retirée mais voilà
alors on est un peu extrême le risque
concours le plus souvent c'est peut-être
plutôt d'être anecdotique être
anecdotique c'est finalement si on prend
un exemple
clairement c'est formidable que le
street art qui était considéré encore
quelques années comme du vandalisme et
maintenant toute sa place dans le monde
de l'art que ce soit devenu un registre
vraiment apprécié du grand public qui
vraiment irrigue toute notre culture
collective de l'image et donc la
publicité mais honnêtement aujourd'hui
combien de campagne de combien de
campagne de com donne l'impression de
maîtres du street art à toutes les
sauces au détriment d'une vraie
réflexion sur finalement l'identité de
la marque en question et les enjeux de
sa connexion un agent artistique donnée
dans un réflexe un peu de facilité et
l'a donc un dernier exemple en date qui
a court encore à quelques kilomètres
d'ici
sur le show room
une grande marque automobile que je
nommerai pas mais vous verrez que c'est
quand même difficile de faire aussi
indifférenciée même si on arrive où on
arrive à dire le alors il ya aussi un
troisième risque il faut faire attention
à pas être parasites être parasites
c'est quoi c'est finalement vouloir
utiliser mobiliser des signes des
éléments culturels sans avoir fait le
travail d'acquérir la légitimité pour ça
là aussi un exemple récent cd t-shirt
h&m et à quelques mois h&m s'est dit
qu'il allait sortir une collection qui
allait finalement utilisé des imprimés
avec des graphismes inspirés de la
culture métal et en fait qu'ils allaient
être l'expression de groupes de métal
fictifs qui inventaient pour l'occasion
bon sauf que les vrais fans devraient
métal ils n'ont pas du tout aimé
ils ont vraiment l'impression d'être
instrumentalisés et donc ils ont réagi
et donc comment on réagit aujourd'hui
sur les réseaux sociaux on a vu fleurir
sur youtube sur facebook les pages et
les contenus rattachés à ces faux groupe
fictif comme étant leur propre
expression avec le lien qui va bien vers
la marque et avec tout le contenu
inapproprié que vous pouvez imaginer ce
genre de mésaventure ça montre que quand
on veut être trop utilitaire trop trop
instrumental avoue trop égoïste bas ça
se voit ça se voit et on se crée plutôt
l'hostilité de ceux pour qui cette
dimension culturelle ou artistique est
vraiment quelque chose d'important de
vécu et sincère donc encore une fois
pour éviter ces écueils parce que oui je
peux vous redonner un dernier exemple
même si orange
juste pour vous dire qu'on peut être à
la fois un culte anecdotique et
parasites là c'est un t-shirt vient de
faire under armour
c'est cette marque d'habillement sportif
vous avez cru bon faire un t-shirt band
of brothers donc qui s'inspirait de
photos très connu à gauche un de ses
marines américains qui plantent leur
drapeau au soir la bataille d'iwo jima
l'une des batailles les plus meurtrières
la guerre du pacifique puis en le
transposant dans le fait d'une bande de
copains qui dresse son panneau de basket
sauf que la levée de boucliers encore
sur les eaux sociaux notamment de
descendants d'enfants de vétérans
américains qui trouve ça totalement
déplacé
relais dans les médias et puis une fille
née au bout de quinze jours excuses
embarrassées de la marque retrait du
produit et c'est donc encore une fois
pour éviter tout ça ces exigences de
légitimité de qualité d'être dans une
vraie sincérité pour être authentique et
puis de vraiment travailler cet ancrage
dans la durée dans la cohérence pour que
vraiment l'entreprise devienne au cours
du temps un vrai acteur de culture et ça
m'amène justement pour conclure à la
dernière idée reçue je voulais partager
avec vous sur ce sujet alors c'est une
idée qui peut paraître un petit peu
provoquant donc j'ai essayé de bien bien
m'ont expliqué c'est cette idée quand
même assez communes en france que non
mais toute façon la culture il ya qu un
seul sujet c'est juste qu'elle doit être
protégé sous-entendu éventuellement y
compris du monde de l'entreprise alors
pour ça je voudrais vous donner une
illustration de l'idée sous jacente que
ya de ça je vous présente le dernier
rhinocéros blanc mâle d'afrique donc le
dernier qui peut éventuellement assurer
la survie de l'espèce
alors lui les protéger voyez c'est pas
pour de rire il ya vraiment des gardes
armés qui se relayent jour et nuit
autour du rhinocéros et puis alors je
sais pas vous savez peut-être les
rhinocéros sont très recherchés pour
leurs cornes et souvent les braconniers
tu les rhinocéros juste pour leur
prendre la corne donc là on s'est dit on
va prendre les devants on lui a scié la
corne comme ça ça éloigne encore plus la
menace
oui est ce que c'est vraiment ça qu'on
veut pour la culture une culture qui
soit tellement protégés isolé mise à
distance au point de décourager toute
interaction
alors attendons nous bien c'est évident
que tout le travail des créateurs des
artistes mais aussi des conservateurs du
patrimoine muséal monumental doit être
protégé doit être encouragée doit être
favorisée que c'est une responsabilité
collective et et même une mission
d'ordre public mais à cet égard
justement rappelons quand même une chose
aujourd'hui sur les 100 plus grandes
entités économiques au monde y en a déjà
près de la moitié qui sont de grandes
entreprises internationales
il n'ya plus que l'autre moitié qui sont
des états donc est-ce qu'on peut
raisonnablement penser que les pouvoirs
publics vont continuer tout seul de
préserver les enjeux
sociaux et culturels c'est juste pas
réaliste et donc aujourd'hui on admet
très largement que l'entreprise a un
rôle sociétal environnemental et ben
l'entreprise doit être aussi un acteur
de culture et pour conclure sur cette
conviction qu'elle peut le faire en
mobilisant en plus des leviers
artistique et que tu rêves dans sa vie
économique normale
je vais invoqué la figure tutélaire
incontournable de steve jobs ce qui
manquait pas une occasion de préciser
qu'il situait lui-même son entreprise
exactement au carrefour de la
technologie et des arts d humanité et
pour tout vous dire quand nous mêmes on
habite dans le nom de notre société mots
à la fois art et marketing qu'elle
suspicion ça a levé dans certains
milieux mais ce que je voudrais vraiment
c est sûr que bat désormais vous
n'aborderai plus le seuil de
l'entreprise en abandonnant votre
dimension culturelle mais qu'au
contraire vous vous serez vous-même
intégrateur de culture merci